- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here
and welcome to Middle School Biology.
I have Iman Howard here who
manages our STEM content.
Welcome Iman, and why should folks care
about middle school biology?
- Biology is the study of life,
and so in this course it really answers
why are things the way they are?
Why do you look the way they do?
Why do I look the way I do?
And how every organism on earth
has a really special purpose
and a special trait, and
based on these traits,
it helps them interact
with their environment.
We even talk about energy,
and energy can't be created
and it can't be destroyed.
It actually cycles as
matter through an ecosystem.
And it even has this really
cool chemical reactions
called photosynthesis where
plants use light energy
from the sun and they make
their own food, which is insane.
I think about organisms like the gorilla
that are super big and strong,
and they don't go and eat a cow.
They go and eat plants
because that's like getting
energy right from the source.
And then finally, we talk about evolution.
Based on our traits, how
have we changed over time?
And how some of our natural
traits were selected
by the environment that
create those changes.
Or even how humans,
we have something called
artificial selection
which explains why your dog's so cute,
whether it's 100 pounds or
five pounds, we did that.
What do you think is cool about it, Sal?
- Oh, well, you know,
biology is trying to answer,
I mean, to your point,
the questions of life,
which we still don't
understand a lot about,
but like what makes us us,
and to realize that we don't exist
as human beings in isolation,
we're part of an ecosystem.
We're part of a story,
a narrative that's been going on
for millions and billions of years.
The fact that we're made
up of trillions of cells,
each of them with DNA that
can describe who we are.
How did all of this complexity come about?
This is maybe the most mind-blowing topic
that we're really at just the
beginning of this journey.
So I think folks are gonna
be really, really excited,
or it's gonna be really interesting
to see all of the things
that they get to learn.
- Well, let's dig in.